sur le terrain l'armée russe mène
également des combats dans la région de
vauxronnage près de la frontière
ukrainienne un dépôt de carburant est en
flamme plus de 100 pompiers 30 véhicules
sont sur place la guerre en Ukraine elle
continue et on retrouve tout de suite
Gwendoline de Bono notre envoyé spécial
à zaporigia comment réagissent les
soldats Ukrainiens à cette crise voir ce
coup de force en Russie
alors d'abord il est le président volody
mirzelinski qui a réagi qui dit celui
qui choisit la voix du mal se détruit
lui-même il dit la Russie la faiblesse
de la Russie est évidente la faiblesse
de la Russie est totale et c'est un peu
ce que l'on entend également de la part
des soldats Ukrainiens alors il y a de
choses nous avons pu parler ce matin un
commandant du renseignement militaire
qui dit que évidemment et bien son unité
observe attentivement ce qui se passe
mais lui dit est bien que ces problèmes
internes ont également fait partie de la
stratégie de l'Ukraine de les provoquer
il dit tout cela va dans la bonne voie
et nous rapproche de la victoire en
revanche sur le front on ne voit pas de
changement notable dans les dans les
lignes de front dans les actes dans les
activités militaires russes il y a
toujours des bombardements il y a
toujours des attaques il y a eu quelques
progrès
de la ville de barmut mais pas on ne
voit pas par exemple des lignes de front
en train de s'effondrer et les soldats
avec qui nous avons parlé ce matin nous
étions ce matin avec des soldats nous
disait bien que il ne regardait pas
particulièrement là ce qui était en
train de se passer mais qu'il restait
concentré sur leur tâche merci beaucoup
Gwendoline de Bono merci à vous